I'd like to start with a confession
which is that I kind of like computers
better than I like people so when I ask
you the question will computers replace
teachers my bias is to say dear God I
hope so
I mean I think you you all have
experienced this phenomenon probably on
the way here when you checked in for
your flight you hopefully if everything
went well used a kiosk instead of
talking to a human at the airport you
needed a little bit of cash you went to
the teller you went to the ATM instead
of talking to a human teller there are
so many places in our society already
that have been made so much better by
removing humans so education as always
unfortunately is lagging in this respect
and what I'd like to talk to you today
is just kind of about how we can solve
that problem and the people out there
who are solving that problem already I
want to kind of look at both ends of the
spectrum so I'll talk kindergarten and
then I'll talk College I think for some
people who aren't familiar with what's
going on out there the idea of online
education for kindergarteners sounds a
little bit absurd you have this sort of
image of people sitting in their parents
basement somewhere with the blue light
of the computer in their face just
typing away lonely but that's actually I
think increasingly not where online
education is going on instead it's to
the the blended learning model that Jim
described a little bit earlier and I'll
get into more of that now the first
thing I want to take a poll who has
young kids or grandkids in the room how
many of you have some kind of an apple
product in your lives how many of you
have had to fight one of those young
kids or grandkids because they
desperately wanted to like smear
applesauce on your Apple right so I have
a two-year-old she honestly loves my
iPhone more than she loves me and the
prospect that we would you know look
forward to her education and sent her
into a building where there will be you
know maybe one computer
classroom or where where they'll be
learning how to add or subtract or do
their ABCs on a piece of paper with a
pencil when right now at age 2 she's
begging me for the flashcards app it
just seems very backwards and wrong and
I think anyone who is who's hung out
with kids will agree these awesome
online education tools though do not do
all the things that we want from our
education system frankly again as the
mother of a two-year-old kids are pretty
annoying and take up a lot of your time
which is why we love school they go away
all day long to another place and you
know warehousing is a dirty word in the
educational establishment and
particularly in traditional schools they
don't really like to point to that fact
about what they do but there's nothing
wrong with warehousing children in fact
we should embrace this function and
schools I hope in the future we'll do it
on a schedule that looks more like the
working schedule of adults in America
the kids could go to a building
somewhere 9:00 to 5:00 all year round
because I don't know about you guys but
I have to go to a building somewhere
from 9:00 to 5:00 all year round and
work luckily it's a reason so it's
awesome but you know this is this is
something that is a real incompatibility
in our systems but warehousing does not
have to mean the sort of dreary machine
like image of Education that we just saw
instead I'd like to tell you about a
couple of sort of huge success stories
that are already going on right now the
first is I think many of you are
probably familiar with the Kipp schools
which are just a sort of runaway success
charter school organization there are
many schools all around the country they
cater mostly to poor and minority kids
so these are in urban neighborhoods
they're generally kids that have been
left behind by the the current education
system there's a bunch of these in
California including a couple of new
ones that opened up in the Los Angeles
area
a couple years ago Kipp empower is one
of them California as we have heard
extensively and we'll hear more is in
the middle of the nation's most
photogenic budget crisis it's just you
know California really does it best
so so of course one of the things that
California is doing is cutting funding
to one of the few things that works in
their education system so a new Kipp
school was set to open up California
decided to cut two hundred thousand
dollars from the budget of the school
which is a big deal for for a school
like Kipp but this was an opportunity so
what they decided to do was try out some
of the new online learning tools that
were out there instead of classrooms of
20 with a teacher and a teacher's
assistant which is the kind of baseline
Kipp model they decided to try out
classrooms of thirty same staffing 15
computers so what this means is this is
a perfect example of blended learning
the kids go all day they have a great
educational culture they have you know a
human who is there who's a certified
teacher and then a teacher's assistant
but at any given time a bunch of the
kids are on the computers which means
you can have reading groups of seven or
ten kids and still have the other 15
kids doing really substantive learning
in fact and this is where I get to the
computers are totally better than people
claim the fifteen kids were on the
computers are probably in many cases
learning more or getting something that
they weren't getting in both traditional
schools and even maybe at other Kipp
schools because the computers have all
these attributes that humans don't have
they are infinitely patient and you know
for anybody who has sung the ABC song
ten thousand times in a desperate
attempt to teach kids that LMNOP is not
one letter
a computer will sing it 10,000 times a
computer will give you a new little clip
art illustration for the letter a every
time over and over until you get it
computers also have great memories so
what happens in with these Kip programs
is that they they record everything that
the kids are doing when they're on the
computers and the teachers or the
teacher's assistants review the kids
scores at the end of the day and they
see oh you know what I wouldn't have
caught this if everybody was just
reciting something out loud in a
classroom but you know little Logan is
having trouble with the difference
between C and K I need to check up on
him on that or you know little little
Timmy doesn't understand that cows and
pigs are different animals we gotta we
gotta buckle down and really focus on
that there are a bunch of amazing
companies that are providing these
products I would I talked to a bunch of
people who have said you know either for
their own kids or for people that they
know they're really looking for ways to
supplement or replace traditional
education education elements is a
for-profit firm that works with Kipp and
it's absolutely worth noting here that a
lot of the providers of these online
tools are for-profit they're there in it
to make money so they're trying to
provide the best most competitive
product out there and these are schools
with limited budgets so they're trying
to get the most bang for their buck it's
like this magic mechanism it's so cool
so you know you can go into you can go
into one of these classrooms in one of
these Kipp classrooms and see kids doing
a reading tutorial on Ice Station which
is one popular program there's an
estimation game on compass learning
where kids follow an animated chef who
throws cinnamon buns at them you know I
wish I had had teachers who threw
cinnamon buns at me but it never
happened and and these kids are gonna
have that have that opportunity you know
the best teachers the absolute best
teachers can know these kinds of things
about their kids almost instinctively
you know I think we've all had really
excellent teachers who have this kind of
grasp of where everyone is in their
classroom all the time and what help
that kid needs most teachers are not the
best
teachers a lot of teachers really really
suck
I mean we're asking a lot of teachers
they have to be babysitters they have to
be mentors they have to be coaches they
have to be subject matter experts
there's no reason why one person should
be performing all those functions
there's no reason why people at all
should be pouring some of them so this
is kind of an opportunity to branch out
from that Kip's results are great across
the board but this particular Kipp
school has been a huge success right
away last year thirty six percent of the
kids incoming kindergartners were
reading at grade level by the end of
that year was 96 percent they just they
do it and they teach kids how to read
rocket ship education is another company
which is which is pretty great they've
been out there a little longer they're
based in San Jose they do a K through
five and about 25 percent of what they
do is online 75% is in-person but again
they're doing it not just better but
cheaper and this is you know
increasingly relevant not just in
California but everywhere the youngest
kids in rocketship and they throw up
these kind of prefab trailers that are
just they're colorful they're nice
they're very cheap they put them up in
poor neighborhoods
everyone at rocketship has reduced price
or subsidized lunch the kids take math
lessons on the computer there's a
program called dream box we're talking
dinosaurs teach them how to add a rocket
ship school is about half a million
dollars cheaper than then its
counterpart for K through five school
what they do with that half a million
dollars is paid teachers more they have
fewer teachers who are better paid this
is a vision that a lot of people have
tried to implement in public schools
Michelle Rhee and DC for those of you
who followed that story you know
basically they do buy off every teacher
in the city in an attempt to offer a
little bit of merit pay to some teachers
just the ones who wanted it and it's all
been reversed since she left so it's
very very hard to figure out ways to pay
teachers more even when they are good at
their jobs and rocket ship has done that
but I want to kind of go even further
down the cost scale and just point out
that for instance in Arizona it cost
about eight thousand dollars to educate
a traditional public school student
carpe diem which is an academy there it
was just based in Yuma they do it for
about a thousand bucks a student you can
go even further down the scale and go to
a really amazing finding for one One
Laptop Per child last year I think they
publicized this they they took a about a
thousand tablets Motorola tablets to a
village in Ethiopia where there was no
literacy so this is not like an
underserved area the United States this
is a place where there are no words and
there's no power and there's nothing
with an on/off switch and they just
dropped a thousand laptops about one for
every kid in the village and they left
them within a few weeks the kids were
singing ABC's they figured out how to
get the buck get him out of their boxes
turn him on I think kids were using an
average of like 40 apps within a couple
months and within five months some kid
had figured out that they had disabled
there was a camera in these tablets and
because of privacy concerns they had
disabled the cameras some kid hacked the
Android operating system and turned on
the camera five months after the first
time he saw a printed word or an
electronic device of any kind we do not
need $10,000 a year worth of public
education for kids to do stuff this is
this is you know we're doing it wrong if
these kids are doing it right so I guess
when you know what I what I just like to
kind of highlight there is that kids
want these computers so badly they just
want to learn online the idea that
somehow the screen time will harm them
or that they won't be appropriately
socialized I think is really misguided
what we're hoping to socialize these
kids to as I think in a lot of cases
white collar jobs like the kind that
most of us are lucky enough to have to
you know to put them into schools that
are structured around the kind of
industrial you know factory worker jobs
that don't even exist anymore
certainly doesn't do them a service and
so now I just like to talk briefly about
the flip end of online education which
is at the
university-level I suspect many of you
already know more about that it's
certainly been in the news a lot the
massively open online courses or the
hilarious hilarious acronym MOOCs are
pretty big these days Coursera and
Udacity or two of the biggest names in
EDX those are coming out of Stanford and
MIT and Harvard and you also probably
know Khan Academy which is aimed mostly
at high achieving high school students
it gives them tutorials of just all
manner of stuff that they might have
trouble picking up in class there's also
little guys who I think are showing a
lot of promise - including George
Mason's Tyler Cowen and Alex Tabarrok
launched marginal revolution university
which is named after their blog which
some of you may read and what they do is
they just have one course right now and
it's just the two of them teaching this
one course because that's what they're
good at and offering it up the problem
right now was online ed for college is
that there's no iTunes of online ed and
there's no Yelp of online ed so it's
hard to know what's good and it's hard
to know what in for employers to know
what's good once people come out of the
far end this is not something that I am
the first person to notice a lot of
these people are trying really really
hard to figure out how to solve this
problem and just in the past few days
actually there's been some interesting
developments including San Jose State
has started offering some of their
remedial courses through Udacity they're
using online courses to teach remedial
statistics and some other things they
cost about $150 a pop which is
significantly cheaper than the credits
that the school is offering in the
traditional environment needless to say
the professors at San Jose State are not
super thrilled about this development
they shouldn't be they should be nervous
they are about to be replaced and I
think too often in the debate about
online education people are very careful
to say oh there's always room for
teachers teachers or you know they're
apple pie and flags and we just you know
we have to give them everything they
want forever and ever there will always
be room for really good teachers there
will also always be room for good
coaches and good mentors and good
counselors but those people are going to
there
who look very very different and you
know I hope that their pay scales will
also look very very different in the in
the near future there's also been
another development which is at the
University of Wisconsin has started
offering say they're gonna start
offering degrees to people who complete
their coursework elsewhere and they'll
just have to take proficiency tests so
this is something that you know we've
gotten pretty far from the idea that you
go to college to learn a set of stuff
and then employers will know you learn
that stuff because you have a degree
this is the chance to kind of get back
to that it's just one of the functions
of college and and like the very best
teachers I think some of the very top
colleges are fine they can do whatever
they want they can keep doing exactly
what they've been doing you know there's
there will always be a demand for a
Harvard degree but you know the San Jose
states of the world better hustle cuz
they are gonna get put out of business
just very quickly I'd like to talk about
policy and of course it's for those of
you supporting your yellow scarves it's
it's school choice week reason is having
a series of events we had one in DC last
week or earlier this week we've got this
event and there's another one in LA
coming up but you can ask Amy about
school choice has the idea of school
choice has definitely evolved and
expanded and no longer just sort of
means the original Milton Friedman
vision of vouchers and charters but also
also now these new online tools so I'm
very excited to kind of be talking about
this in that context today there are
some policy barriers which you might not
be shocked to hear - - adopting some of
these reforms one of the biggest is
actually one of the most obvious for K
through 12 which is seat time
requirements many many states have
requirements the kids have to have their
butts in chairs within the view of a
teacher for X number of hours every week
that doesn't make any sense but of
course the reasons for those rules are
obvious this is a great job security
measure for teachers unions it's a great
way to make sure that
even when there are other budgetary
pressures that teachers jobs remain
protected there's also the problem of
September to June school year for
anybody who has ever you know moved in
the middle of the year you know this is
like a classic child trauma saying that
you have to you know do third grade over
because your new district doesn't
recognize the credits from your old
district and that's a huge possible
benefit of these online courses is that
they could be interoperable across many
many different systems and in fact you
could continue education completely
uninterrupted even if your parents have
to move for a job there's also the
possible benefit of people being able to
stay in urban areas I live in Washington
DC and I have a young child things don't
look that good for school if I want to
send her to public school and this is
why people you know creative class
workers who would prefer to stay in
cities wind up having to leave it's it's
you know it's not good for those cities
it's not good for the workers it's maybe
not even good for the kids who are
missing out on the kind of benefits of
living in urban areas which they're
simply not possible because of because
of the quality of public schools in
those areas and teacher-to-student
ratios or another problem they don't
make any sense in a world where you know
some of the teaching is done by a
physical teacher who has full
credentials some of the teaching is done
by someone who's an assistant some of
the teaching could be done by somebody
in India who's in your headset saying
hey why don't we try again on that math
problem you know that's I know you can
do it right you can say that from India
it's no problem
and the person's name will be like bulb
it'll be great
but you know there's the biggest problem
and the biggest barrier here is just the
huge political risk to people who want
to innovate in this area there are
people who are dying to get into online
education in fact there are people in
this room who I've talked to over the
last day or so who are dying to get into
online education we've got folks
designing financial literacy courses
we've got people who want to help out
their their friends and neighbors who
are looking for a ways to to improve
their own kids lot but as long as
at the whim of the machine it's not
worth it to invest a ton of money it's
not worth it to invest a ton of time
it's not worth it to stake your
professional future on something that
could be wiped out by you know an
obscure vote in the state legislature in
the middle of the night by 10 guys who
were bought off by teachers unions which
is what happens all the time I mean I'm
not exaggerating when I say that you
know charter schools are often an inn
for online education but there are many
states now where you can't enroll in a
charter even if you have statewide
choice you can't enroll in a charter
that's online focused unless you live in
the district where the Charter is hosted
I don't think they're totally clear on
how the internet works in that case
because the internet costs all the
districts so you know and it's all about
money it's all about funding so I don't
want to end on a on a kind of
pessimistic note so I'm going to end on
a quasi optimistic note which is that I
don't know if we can you know ultimately
reform institutions so that the kind of
blended learning model that I've
described comes to public schools comes
to traditional public schools but I do
know that it's a lot easier to opt out
for people who have been daunted by the
idea of homeschooling for people who are
daunted by the idea of the price of a
private school you know charters and
vouchers have already made this much
more of a real possibility for families
who would otherwise have just been stuck
with you know real estate as destiny for
their schools but I think we're just
gonna see more and more of that you know
you can you can envision all kinds of
things including the flipped school day
where kids consume their lectures at
night and just hang out with tutors
during the day you can imagine vast
warehouses holding kindergarteners or
18-year olds who just want to get out of
the house but would rather you know take
their courses online
you know for-profit providers will will
step up here if if the other components
are there so I don't know if we can fix
it
yet although I do think we can fix it
eventually but I do know that there are
a lot of ways to choose not to be a part
of the dysfunctional school system that
we have right now
and they're increasingly online